hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to overgrowth a game where
you play a furry little bunny rabbit and
you dived up dodge duck dip dive and
dodge your way through a series of
canyons and mountains and different
pillars and cities to try to escape the
evil creatures all stell bunnies and
maybe wolves that are trying to kill you
with whatever they can get their hands
on so let's get into it I'm gonna start
with the arena because that's what I've
been playing the most so far I've only
got about maybe twenty five minutes into
this thing but basically you're your
character and it's all custom-built and
you can fight by punching and kicking
and it's all physically based the
damages all physicals though yeah I got
him down he squeaked a little bit before
he died yeah kick to the balls so anyway
there's two rounds to certain games and
then you get up cuz you didn't just get
blunt-force trauma to the head but oh
did I mention it's kind of hard you can
also jump really high yeah yeah I said
come on stop twirling like a ballerina
and kick him don't kick your own teeth
yeah you like that I kick you when
you're down good good job teammate ooh I
have a sword look at me everybody I have
a sword it's a fight to the death this
game actually is kind of brutal what are
you doing well I thought you were my
teammate now please okay I'm not that
they didn't hit me with the sword haha
I'm just gonna let them all fight I'm
gonna do you stay away from me you stay
already stay away from me oh oh
you can't skip my mad moves brother my
sick
[Applause]
yeah you all jealous that my mad skills
over here I'm just bleeding like pretend
bleeding if you two could stop dancing
over there that'd be delightful
I'm professionally skilled at everything
combat what was he doing there was like
don't excuse me I'm gonna take this body
back to my home you you ignore me
ignore me man I'm I just need this
excuse me I please do I can you leave me
alone for like two seconds I need this I
need this I need this for something I
need this for stuff and things hello
friend you and I team up and then we do
good okay oh no I'm gonna get you you
can't stop my crafting Tiger kung-fu
Tigger bunny style you want somebody huh
oh don't mind me oh what's going on over
there who you messing with me
walk into my circle over here you [ __ ]
come on bring it on bring it on
b9 we know what you skinny well yeah
there we go I do that I am neo
I am neo Bunny and the Energizer Bunny I
can't stop me I just keep going and
going and going
oh I kept going Oh another round god I
was oh
that's gonna get for celebrating way too
early
send you across the friggin map also
guys I learned that you could do this
[Laughter]
don't matter I'm a wolf boom are you not
that are turned
hey buddy hey buddy hey buddy hey buddy
hey you want a wolf job you want a wolf
star buddy hey buddy hey buddy you seen
them wolf down what are you doing what
do you do
[Applause]
hardly seems fair
oh god I am Marc bot ready to destroy
you hey Marc
Oh mark but hurt in part but mark much
better now
what about turn into mark wolf merges
[Music]
[Applause]
stay Jamie three two one and death
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh there's death who's a delayed death
there we go there we go
asked what I'm talking about that's what
I'm sizzles saying oh no no no no oh
poor wolfie Sandy zone Bears oh that was
an embarrassment to my family I'm on our
route I miss oh come on but no stop it
I'm trying to please can I please can I
please can i oh this is a bad idea gonna
get you oh didn't kill you I'll get Jill
oh the old-fashioned way with a frickin
wolf come here [ __ ] ow
how are you so why are you so you killed
my wolf not this wolf though I back up
again oh come on it's nice really good
come on
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's all